[Musique]
bonjour à tous la grande interview merci
de cette fidélité la grande interview
cette semaine avec robert cigale
professeur robert cigale vous êtes
médecin
mais ce qui est plus rare c'est que vous
êtes aussi directeur général d'un
hôpital et pas n'importe lequel
puisqu'il s'agit de l'hôpital américain
alors merci d'être là
l'hôpital américain ben c'est à neuilly
tout le monde de tout le monde connaît
parce que pour beaucoup mais je sais que
là je vais vous fâchez c'est quand même
l'hôpital des riches quoi on doute on
doit vous la faire tout le temps mais
c'est vrai mais ceci va d'abord merci de
votre invitation et c'est vrai que
l'image qui colle à l'hôpital américain
c'est celle d'hôpital des riches
alors pourquoi moi je crois que c'est
parce que l'hôpital accueille depuis
longtemps des personnalités du monde
politique du monde médiatique du sport
et que les médias s'en sont fait écho à
plusieurs reprises la question dans le
fond c'est de comprendre pourquoi ces
personnes viennent à l'hôpital américain
et elles viennent pour une seule raison
pas parce que c'est un hôpital des
riches
elles viennent parce que c'est un
hôpital où il y à l'excellence médicale
c'est la seule raison pour laquelle en
gros on va en parler en détail de
l'offre
finalement on parlera aussi du prix 1
que ça peut coûter parce que ça
intéresse ça intéresse tout le monde va
revenir sur cette marque de fabrique
donc mais avant je voulais vous demander
si vous aviez en tant que professionnel
et puis en tant que praticien une
lecture particulière de l'épidémie là
qui est en train de se répandre sur la
planète toute entière qui nous vient de
chine
le coronavirus bien sûr vous ne pouviez
pas prévenir ça vous l'avez pris comment
vous l'avez écouté le coroner virus
c'est une un épisode effectivement qui
s'est déjà produit puisqu'il ya eu
l'épisode du sras s'il y avait un autre
épisode qu'on appelait la mairesse donc
c'est pas la première fois qu'on est
exposé à ces épisodes infectieux
ce que je peux vous dire d'abord pour
donner un point de vue de mon hôpital
c'est que l'hôpital américain se prépare
évidemment de façon extrêmement sérieuse
à cet épisode en prenant toutes les
mesures à la réception il fait tout ce
qui est nécessaire en fait les tests à
l'arrivée des urgences
non actuellement les tests quand il ya
une suspicion sont envoyés sur pasteur
les tests seront disponibles pasteur
annonce qui me disent qu'ils enverront
l'ex que les kits de test à partir de la
semaine prochaine dans les hôpitaux donc
actuellement les tests sont sont
rapatriés mais quand une suspicion de
patients qui à ce type de problème parce
que ce sont des gens tout ce qu'ils ont
une forte fièvre
si la suspicion est suffisamment
sérieuse on les envoie sur les hôpitaux
de référence et pour notre hôpital
c'est l'hôpital bichat en france
actuellement fois paris en tout cas il
ya bishai à la pitié il ya necker
enfants malades pour les enfants et il
ya des gens qui sont les hôpitaux qui
reçoivent ces patients comment
jugez-vous la façon dont les chinois ont
géré cette affaire
au départ la gère maintenant et la façon
dont il réagit écouter enfin l'om est
d'abord le remess dit que la gestion est
correct déjà nommé le juge de sa bien
entendu mieux que quiconque
maintenant ce qu'on voit surtout par
comparaison c'est que quand au début des
années 2000 une infection sérieuse la
gestion avait été franchement très
masqué et là on voit qu'un effort de
transparence qui est indiscutable
je pense que de toutes les façons les
autorités y était contrainte parce que
il ya ce qu'on appelle c'est le palois
de sable ça s'appelle louis chat sur les
réseaux chinois et les jambes cause il
se trouve que j'ai parlé ce matin à mes
amis qui dirige un grand hôpital de
guangzhou canton qui est en fait 1000 km
au sud du centre de l'épidémie est
lapidé y viennent toucher cette ville
donc ils sont maintenant préoccuper les
gens sont confinés ça commence à se
disséminer mais quand je lui ai posé la
question est ce que les autorités aient
dit oui on sait maintenant lié à une
forme de transparence de l'information
donc jusqu'à preuve du contraire les
autorités chinoises gère l'épisode de
façon correcte parce que au départ on a
pris un peu de retard
trois semaines du temps parce que les
autorités locales avaient un peu
dissimuler l'information
c'est toujours compliqué
enfin la lecture rétrospective est
toujours est-ce qu'ils ont été aussi
transparent que aussi que bon c'est bien
placé pour vous pour en juger
en tout cas actuellement au stade de
l'épidémie ils sont manifestement
coopèrent font le nécessaire pour que
pour contenir les choses vous sentez
beaucoup de de curiosité beaucoup de
besoins d'informations de la part de vos
patients oui de la part des familles de
patients oui alors indiscutablement
c'est devenu un sujet de préoccupation
c'est même frappant de voir à quel point
et je dois dire que par rapport à sa
maintenance au regard de la situation
française
je trouve que le ministère de la santé
la direction générale de la santé
l'agencé régionale de santé fait
franchement un excellent job entre les
informations qu'on nous donne à nous en
tant que professionnel et celle qu'on
donne au public
joignez le 15 et c'est franchement le
niveau d'information est tout à fait et
d'organisation est tout à fait
satisfaisant madame busin fait un
excellent job il ya une personne
auxquelles je voudrais rendre hommage
qui est le professeur jérôme salomon qui
est le directeur général de la santé
lui-même est un infectiologue réputé
c'est parfaitement de quoi il parle
et donc voilà on sent que les choses
sont tenues sont tenues en main alors
pour le professionnel le pic de
l'épidémie va être atteint à quel moment
quand est ce qu'on va pouvoir te dire
pandémie ou c'est peut-être alors les
critères de pandémie c'est évidemment un
nombre de pays touchés
un nombre de personnes touchées on
appâte n'a pas de pandémie déclarée
et on voit que le nombre de cas augmente
à quel moment l'om est-ce d'éclat
décidera de déclarer qu'il ya une
pandémie et surtout votre question à
quel moment ça se terminera là dessus je
crois qu'il réponse actuellement
malheureusement a donné là dessus bien
alors on va revenir à votre deuxième
casquette acquis et la casquette de
directeur général de manager
de l'hôpital américain si une entreprise
tout dépend de ce qu'on entend par le
mot entreprises d'abord l'hôpital
américain est une fondation à but non
lucratif c'est souvent oublié tous les
jours nation à but non lucratif alors
qu'est ce que ça veut dire parce que
tous les gens imaginent l'hôpital
américain sait quelque chose
des actionnaires est fait alors
absolument pas l'hôpital américain a été
créé avant la guerre de 14 est devenue
une fondation à but fondation après la
guerre de 14 à cause des services
éminents qu'elle avait rendu aux soldats
français blessés et donc ce statut de
fondation à but non lucratif et qu' elle
ne distribue aucun dividende à ses
actionnaires il n'y a pas d'actionnaire
si elle fait des bénéfices elle doit
faire des bénéfices comme toute
entreprise bien gérée elle les
réinvestit intégralement dans des
bâtiments dans des équipements de
l'information qualifiée elle veut
investir si elle veut s'équiper si elle
veut aller grossir il faut qu'elle fasse
appel
accès à ses donateurs il faut que je
fasse appel à ses donateurs on a une
partie de donateurs mais on a surtout
gestion saine qui fait qu'on dégage des
bénéfices qui nous permettent d'investir
juste pour cet aspect business l'hôpital
américain est un hôpital de relativement
petite taille dans le paysage français
puisque qu'on a 130 lits
ouais on a un chiffre d'affaires de 128
120 millions d'euros
mais on est très peu endetté et surtout
on a un plan d'investissements de
l'ordre de 180 millions d'euros sur cinq
ans ce qui est considérable et ce qui
reflète une saine gestion
alors on va parler de ce que vous allez
faire de de cet argent
quel est le rapport avec l'hôpital
public qu'elle est là la relation que
vous avez avec le système hospitalier
français le système de santé français
écoutez d'abord à titre personnel moi
j'étais le directeur médical de gustave
roussy j'ai passé 20 ans dans le service
public donc c'est un service que je
connais bien et que j'admire qui est un
excellent service maintenant l'hôpital
américain et là aussi il ya une sorte de
fontanes d'hôpital américain serait hors
sol un peu bas on est en france on est
complètement dans le système français
par exemple on est surveillé par la
haute autorité de santé françaises comme
tous les hôpitaux français
on est vérifié la qualité des soins la
qualité de l'hôpital et on a on vient
d'être accrédité par e.on rang acquis et
le rang le plus élevé comme 30% des
hôpitaux français on est également
surveillé par l' agence régionale de
santé d'île de france
avec lequel les choses se passent bien
dans quelques jours le directeur général
de la rs aurélia rousseau sera chez nous
les choses se passent bien troisièmement
on a des relations étroites avec la
faculté de médecine
l'université paris descartes qui vient
de nous accorder des postes de
professeurs associés
donc voilà on est complètement dans
l'éco système sanitaire français et on a
des relations travail aussi les hôpitaux
de notre environnement avec l'hôpital
foch avec l'hôpital san jose voilà on
est dans l'écosystème vous avez une
relation particulière avec le système
financier de la santé c'est à dire la
sécurité sociale
bien sûr j'y arrive aux urgences sur
alors totalement je montre ma carte
vitale et et la légende dit une carte
premier de bancaire monsieur sylvestre à
la vous êtes victime l'intérieur mais
c'est une question se pose alors mais
vous attendez je les comprends parce que
beaucoup de gens ont l'impression qu'ils
ne seraient pas remboursés sur l'hôpital
américain c'est faux c'est faux alors on
parle de patients sécurité sociale on
parlera pas ses internationaux tout à
l'heure un et pour les patients sécurité
sociale ils sont remboursés par la
sécurité sociale sur lui sur la base des
actes alors la petite nuance qu'on aura
l'hôpital américain c'est que dans un
hôpital public lire un remboursement
il en est 100% 81,18 nous c'est 80% mais
il ya une base de remboursement de
sécurité sociale et si les soins coûtent
plus cher chez nous il ya ce qu'on
appelle les mutuelles et nos patients
des mutuelles qui fait que pour revenir
à votre hôpital des stars n'ont pas sûr
habituels ne sont pas des stars dès lors
c'est monsieur non messieurs je veux
bien vous croire mais il révèle une
petite partie de vip oui c'est vrai
acteur de cinéma d où d où des grands
patrons de multinationales sûrement
puisqu'ils ont parfois des accidents
survient sur le titre ces gens là vous
dites ils payent pas le même prix ils
paient pas de multi que soit le même
prix que le malade a nourri paie le même
prix
tous les malades fait la même chose avec
talent les gains il n'y a pas un tarif
pour paraître de la clientèle non non
non
non non non il a même pris pour le
bonheur n'a pas de prix au vip pas privé
puis je voulais passer leurs bases
on pourrait faire une chose pareille
c'est à leur assurance qui fonctionne et
c'est leur assurance qui fonctionne mais
d'autres exemples en france 2 vous avez
des concurrents france sur ce créneau là
alors l'hôpital privé à but non lucratif
oui alors qu'en france il ya des
hôpitaux à but non lucratif il ya ce
qu'on appelle on nous explique c'est un
moins un peu technique mais par exemple
les centres anticancéreux sont à but non
lucratif c'est du public
c'est des hôpitaux publics par l'état
christophe rousset n'a par exemple mais
qui a une structure financière un peu
différente de nous donc pas tous les
hôpitaux ne sont publiques en france il
ya des hôpitaux aussi privé à but non
lucratif y en a d'autres les fondations
mais on n'est pas les seuls notre
enfance il ya des hôpitaux qui sont
strictement privé sur wii est bien celui
là maintenant alors maintenant il ya des
hôpitaux seraient en train de rêver il
ya des grands groupes
il ya des grands groupes privés ramsey
health and key ceux qui ont qui sont
montés en puissance d'ailleurs depuis
trente ou quarante ans et qui ont créé
une excellente offre de soins privés
absolument absolue mais nous sommes un
peu voilà un peu un peu particulier oui
parce que ces hôpitaux privés eux sont à
but lucratif
ils ont des actionnaires distribuent des
dividendes ça n'est pas notre en 40
secondes qui l'a d'américains alors déjà
il a une histoire américaine de
formation vous pourriez dire à la
libération non en 14604 après la guerre
de 14
voilà c'est écrit même avant la guerre
de 14 et donc c'est l'origine mais
pourrait dire maintenant qu'est ce qu'il
en reste il en reste quatre choses
premièrement on a un conseil de
surveillance dont la majorité des
membres ce qu'on appelle les gouverneurs
sont américains il fonce à titre
bénévole puisqu'ils reçoivent pas de
dividende
deuxièmement on est surveillé sur le
plan de la qualité par deux organismes
la haute autorité de santé mais
également ce qu'on appelle la jones
comme mission ils surveillent l'hôpital
et on est le seul hôpital à être
surveillé par cet organisme
en dehors du sol des états unis et donc
ils nous surveillent nine double
surveillance française et américaine et
la surveillance américaine est beaucoup
plus strict parce que la surveillance
française il arrive en prévenant
plusieurs mois al avance les américains
ils arrivent le matin sans vous prévenir
donc vous imaginez que les les
conditions de surveillance sont beaucoup
plus dur qu'en france tout simplement
parce qu ils ne préviennent pas des bars
qui viennent petite précision c'est un
audit financier non c'est un management
d'organisation ou cet anneau dit
thérapeutique anneaux dit thérapeutique
et d'organisation est ce que
les évacuations de patients en cas de
problèmes sont organisées est ce que le
dossier passerait bien tenu à ce que les
procédures quand vous piquer un malade
d'une infirmière et bien tenue est ce
que la pharmacie c'est purement
absolument pas fini 13e anodine en
dessous mais aussi à 4 ça c'est la
deuxième chose
la troisième chose c'est qu'on est le
seul hôpital en france avoir le droit
d'accueillir des médecins américains qui
allure n'ont pas le droit d'exercer nom
peut accueillir jusqu'à huit médecins
américains qui peuvent exercer et c'est
le cas on a des médecins américains et
la quatrième chose qui actuellement pour
nous la plus importante c'est qu'on a
des liens très forts avec le new york
presbyterian hospital qui est un énorme
hôpital qui est lui-même lié à columbia
et cornell et on échange des médecins on
échange les infirmières on ne fait des
colocs avec eux l'année dernière on a
fait un colloque sur intelligence
artificielle et imagerie médicale avec
columbia on a mis en place même des
protocoles à la recherche avec je vous
arrête on s'arrête lui une poignée de
secondes revient justement sur vos
spécialités a tout de suite
[Musique]
bien on se retrouve avec robert sigad 7
directeur général d'hôpital america
votre vision du système de santé
français aujourd'hui dont on dit qu'il
est très malade dont on dit qu'il est
très fragile
il est très chahuté et bousculé écoutez
moi je pense qu'il ya quelques
indicateurs qui montrent qu'on a un des
meilleurs systèmes de santé du monde il
faut aussi garder raison
l'om est quand on regarde l'espérance de
vie quand on regarde ne serait-ce que la
couverture financière
et là on est un des meilleurs systèmes
du monde peut parler des états unis il
yad'excellents aux hôpitaux aux états
unis mais quand on voit une partie de la
population qui n'est pas couverte
bon voilà donc en france il faut garder
ça maintenant est-ce que tout fonctionne
bien en français ce que non il ya
évidemment un certain nombre de
problèmes et je suis pas le mieux placé
pour en parler mais on voit bien qu'il
ya des secteurs en difficulté
bon ça c'est assez évident donc que
espérer que les choses se risque à votre
avis introduire un peu de concurrence
dans ce système améliorera les choses
sur le comportement des équipes
médicales ou sur même la gestion des
hôpitaux
écoutez moi là dessus j'ai vu assez
clair c'est à dire je pense que dans le
domaine régalien ont fait pas de
concurrence en permettre la police en
concurrence avec une autre police ou
l'armée qu'une autre armée mais pour le
reste je pense que la concurrence et est
un facteur de progrès indiscutables et
l'hôpital dans le reste oui on le met
tout à fait et d'ailleurs
bah ça a été en réalité l'histoire de du
système hospitalier français depuis
quarante ans quand j'étais un jeune
interne les petites cliniques privées
mois était tout petit si je puis dire
en quarante ans elle se se développer
ont prospéré donc ça fait un challenge
son public et privé moi je pense que ça
stimule je pense que c'est une bonne
chose mais ce que le classement qui sont
publiées par les journaux sur la qualité
et la performance des équipes médicales
dans ici ou là jouent un rôle
oui elle joue un rôle pour le public bon
sens pour cent des gens qui sont bien
classés trouve que c'est formidable et
ceux qui ne sont pas bien classés vont
les critiquer peut-être il ya juste une
petite base de méthodologie c'est que
les classements repose beaucoup sur le
nombre en disant plus l'hôpital
traite de patients plus il est aguerri
ce qui est globalement vrai il ya juste
une petite chose qu'on dit pas trop
c'est que vous vous arrivez dans un
hôpital où on traite 1000 cancers du
sein ce qui serait intéressant 6 heures
si le chirurgien qui veut s'occupe de
vous il en fait 10 par an ou s'emparant
seul artiste à qui est interdit
et ça vous ne commence à voir si le
médecin qu'on a en face de nous qu'on ne
choisit pas toujours parce qu'on ne
choisit pas l'endroit où un accident de
voiture ou une crise cardiaque
c'est vrai c'est pas le guide michelin
comment savoir que c'est un bon médecin
allez vous poser une question de fond
alors qu'un parce qu'il ya des bons
médecins et puis il ya des bombes non
mais écoutez il ya une réponse il ya ce
qu'on appelle la réaccréditation je vous
explique quand un médecin rentrer chez
nous il doit montrer ce qu'on appelle
ses titres ses travaux en fait expliqué
qu'il a fait tout ce qu'il faut tous les
diplômes ça ça n'a rien d'original tous
les hôpitaux vont me demander mais chez
nous tous les médecins repasse tous les
deux ans tous les deux ans devant une
commission qui va regarder ce qu'ils ont
fait sur deux ans est ce que les
traitements ont été conformes à ce qu'on
appelle les bonnes pratiques
est ce que la relation avec les patients
s'est passée sans heurts est ce que les
dossiers patients étaient bien tenus
et cette ré accréditation est une
garantie de sécurité pour les patients
pour les replacer dans le public non
alors attendez il ya non c'est non mais
pour être clair au début quand ça a été
fait les médecins était très opposé en
disant comment vivent actuellement nos
médecins ils voient une forme de
sécurité
mais oui c'est en train de venir dans le
public c'est à dire qu'il ya eu un
rapport fait par le doyen usant il y a
deux ans et l'année dernière à
l'assemblée nationale il ya une demande
que maintenant cette accréditation soit
étendue à tous les hôpitaux français
à quel moment ça va se faire et à quelle
vitesse mais moi je pense qu'une
profonde inégalité pour le système de
santé sur fait ce qu'on appelle
l'inégalité de l'information quand vous
êtes dans une famille et que vous
connaissez évidemment va vous dire vous
allez vas voir untel untel très bien et
après tout tant mieux je dis pas que
mais pour quelqu'un qui sait pas comment
il sait que de l'ail des bois et ça moi
je trouve que c'est au service au
système en général et aux hôpitaux
quelque part d'apporter une forme de
garantie que le médecin que vous avez en
face de vous et bah écoutez il a passé
un certain nombre de tests
il a été enfin kate est à la fois
qu'elle a été vue que sa pratique a été
auditée moi personnellement j'y suis
favorable au jour d'aujourd'hui qui
recrutent les médecins dans les hôpitaux
publics
alors c'est à fait mystérieux c'est pas
très transparent le système d'écouté
enfin là vous me ramenait les souvenirs
de jeux qui recrute quelqu'un définir
tout à fait normal vous êtes interne
vous êtes chef de clinique on veut
passer dans l'enseignement pas
réellement très souvent dans les
établissements publics ça commence parce
que les étudiants en médecine font leur
cursus mme avec d'apprentissage dont le
dans les grands hôpitaux universitaires
et donc souvent au vu de ce qu'ils sont
leur proposera un poste c'est il n'y a
pas deux il n'y a pas de rien mystérieux
de deux ans non non c'est pas voilà et
puis ensuite quand vous montez dans la
hiérarchie par exemple pour devenir
professeur des universités vous allez le
voir passer un concours difficile avec
des appels des tiny des travaux est ce
qu'on a fait des publications vous allez
passer devant vos pairs donc ou non
c'est un cursus bien réglementé vous
comprenez qu'il se soit mis en grève
écoutez j'ai pas la situation moi ce que
je peux je peux se dit juste dire c'est
que je comprends parfaitement que là
qu'on demande aux hôpitaux d'être bien
géré c'est pas un hôpital public je peux
comprendre c'est pas une question de
bénéfices ou de faire et c'est pas ça
qu'on demande
mais la bonne gestion est nécessaire
parce que tout simplement elle va
garantir comme nous le faisons nous
mêmes qu'on pourra réinvestir dans des
bâtiments dans dedans de la dent de la
formation et par exemple ce qui vient
d'être annoncé sur la reprise de la
dette par le ministère je trouve ça bien
il me semble en bonne logique qu'elle
doit être reprise pour des
investissements et pas pour du
fonctionnement si on utilise cet argent
pour explication à payer des salaires
pas sûr que ce soit tout à fait ça
maintenant une fois que j'ai parlé
d'hôpital bien géré je voudrais revenir
aux professionnels particulier aux
médecins
moi je crois que les médecins dans le
public ils veulent préserver ce que je
peux rappeler leur part de rêve
c'est à dire ils sont à l'hôpital pour
faire des études au sens des études
cliniques pour faire des publications
j'espère juste que dans le système
public on continue à leur proposer cette
part de rêve qu'on leur qu'on leur donne
des demandes de la part de deux défauts
qu'il fasse un effort sur la gestion
aussi parce qu'il ya la part de rêve
il faut qu'elle soit financée c'est pour
ça que vous évitez de vous savez il faut
qu'ils la part de gestion mais qui
permettent une part de rêve ne peut pas
être uniquement dans la gestion
comptable faut aussi que la part de rêve
je pense que les aubes les taux doivent
être sur les deux les salaires sur
meilleur chez vous pour attirer les
meilleurs les au niveau des médecins
comme au niveau des aides soignants
d'abord nous ne versons pas de sa mère
parce que nos médecins sont libéraux oui
c'est tellement médecins ne sont pas ne
sont pas ce ne sont pas nous affirme
hier nous affermir son salarié
lp bon franchement elles ne gagnent pas
plus qu'ailleurs par contre ce qu'elles
ont certainement de différent c'est que
le ratio d'infirmières par lee voyez le
nombre
quand vous prenez une l2
enfin quand vous allez regarder combien
d'infirmières dans une unité de soins y
en aura plus chez nous et dont kenza
c'est vrai qu'on a aussi un niveau
d'équipements importants donc leurs
conditions de travail pour faire court
sont bonnes elles le savent très bien le
reconnaissent elles ont des conditions
de travail qui sont qui sont bonnes ce
qui a retenu mon attention quand vous
avez été nommé c'est que vous avez dit
je veux que l'hôpital que je vais
diriger maintenant devienne l'un des
cinq plus performants de france
quels critères vous ne peut pas être
performant partout non sûr qu'un objet
un des cinq premiers hôpitaux
internationaux en europe du coup la
question c'est quelles sont les cinq
meilleurs hôpitaux en europe
en réalité ça dépend un peu par
spécialité si vous demandez dans le
monde de la cancérologie que je connais
bien on veut dire ah bon le royal
marsden à londres le mk ya amsterdam
l'institut des tumeurs à milan curry
gustave roussy
donc voilà donc la question ne peut pas
comparer nokia globalement c'est plutôt
par aspect si vos possible c'est quoi
alors nous ciblons alors ont d'abord
nous on se doit des bons partout déjà et
on a d'excellents médecins selon des
données partout mais si on doit faire un
effort supplémentaire il ya trois
domaines ont fait un effort
supplémentaire d'abord c'est sur le pôle
ce qu'on appelle mère enfant tout ce qui
est maternité accouchement ensuite tout
ce qui va avec c'est tout ce qui est
l'assistance médicale à la procréation
ou là aussi on a fait les choses très
innovantes en matière de technologie et
on continue à le faire
le deuxième axe c'est le cancer du sein
où là aussi on a fait beaucoup de choses
innovantes avec de l'intelligence
artificielle avec des prises en charge
complètement innovante et le troisième
c'est tout ce qui est cancers
urologiques la prostate en faire pour
faire court et tout ce qui va autour des
trois axes sur lequel on développe
particulière alors vous vous parlez
beaucoup de l'intelligence artificielle
derrière il ya les robots ça va tuer le
métier de médecin ça va ça va tuer son
diagnostic c'est un peu ça là un des
fantasmes des inquiétudes de
l'intelligence artificielle alors à
d'abord je voudrais dire une chose moi
mais ma spécialité
le médecin s'était l'imagerie médicale
donc j'ai été dans toute ma vie au
coûterait au contact de tous la
révolution qui est avec les scanner
l'irm le pet enfin voilà donc les pleins
d'évolution technologique donc le
radiologue va opérer
non mais ce qu'on voit maintenant c'est
que l'image l'intelligence artificielle
devienne réalité tous les jours donc
c'est pas un truc on se dit dans dix ans
on commence à voir des choses mais
maintenant pour répondre directement
votre question
les médecins seront toujours là les
infirmières sont toujours là enfin à
l'horizon je serai pas là dans trente ou
quarante ans je veux pas revenir mais
par contre leur métier sera différent je
donne un exemple concret on utilise nos
dépôts des programmes d'intelligence
artificielle sur le cancer du poumon sur
des scanners le programme permet de lire
ils ont sans scanner et va mettre de
côté 90 scanner où il va dire c'est
normal mais il est sûr c'est 90 scanners
sont normaux c'est certain y a pas
d'erreur du coup le radiologue peut se
concentrer sur les disques anr sur
lequel ben ali ses patrons et
l'interrogation est l'interrogation et
du coup le temps du radiologue et mieux
utiliser sur les scanners un peu
problématique et arrive à mieux et tout
ça bien sûr pour le bénéfice du patient
tu auras meilleure sécurité du
diagnostic de la part du rhône est haut
niveau en france
ce niveau là dans ces technologies là
alors là on bénéficie d'un écosystème à
nouveau extraordinaire écouter j'étais
ce matin à cannes a géré du corps des
mines
on a des ingénieurs de première bourre
en france on a des cerveaux
extraordinaire donc oui on est au niveau
la question sera plus de savoir si on
est une start up nation si je puis dire
et si l'écosystème qui permet à des
start-up de de grandir
nous on a un partenariat avec une boîte
formidable qu'il appelle insep taux a
été créée par quelques jeunes ingénieurs
on a des programmes d'intelligence
artificielle dans le cancer du poumon
dans le cancer du sein et sur les
maladies neurologiques comme la sclérose
en plaques
bon cette start up on l'a nous
accompagnons l'accompagnent ont fait
tout pour passer on n'est même plus un
mot de recherche on va être en mode
production soins si je puis dire et le
programme qu'on avait que c'est que nos
patients de façon courante bénéficier
des avancées qu'elles nous permettre et
ce type de boîte
on est très heureux travail que cette
start up française on espère tous que
elle va d'ailleurs elle à elle a déjà
levé du capital je dois vous dire et on
espère tous que les publics public les
pouvoirs publics disent de purs moments
qu'a va grandir prospérer comme d'autres
en france je plutôt confiant ce qui est
très en avance dans le monde là dessus
sur les problèmes d'intelligence
artificielle absurde et appliquée à la
santé la france on n'est pas en retard
les états unis bien sûr là ont une
avance importante les chinois
investissent massivement les israéliens
sont très bon là dessus aussi
donc voilà il ya plusieurs pays qui sont
bons dans cette compétition ça demande
des investissements importants
oui et non sa demande de licence mon nom
parce que
en l'occurrence ce qu'ils demandent
alors il ya un aspect c'est ce qu'on
appelle souvent la datation c'est à dire
qu'est ce qui est en train de
révolutionner le monde de la santé
c'est le fait que vous avez accès
maintenant à des millions de données
comment j'étais à ma génération disons
dans les années 2000 quand vous publiez
un article scientifique
à propos de d'une pathologie vous
faisait un article à propos de 100
malades et tous m'ont trouvé ça
formidable que vous ayez réussi à
vincent malades maintenant vous avez
accès à travers le monde et data le
numérique des milliers des dizaines ou
des centaines de milliers dans le monde
entier dans le monde entier
et là les le modèle économique c'est que
si les petites boîtes sont capables de
se brancher sur ses data a peu de gens
ils peuvent faire des choses extrêmement
innovant donc ce n'est pas
nécessairement un géant qui va faire ça
s'appelle des petites boîtes qui peut
faire ça est ce que c'est un outil
politique ou est-ce que ça peut devenir
un outil politique aux mains de deux de
certaines nations les progrès dans la
santé on le voit bien avec cette
histoire de virus ou données ou les
informations étaient mondialisée assez
rapidement dans l'intérêt de tout le
monde mais dans les secteurs aussi
pointus que les vôtres ça peut être un
avantage compétitif à la connais déjà la
santé est un enjeu politique la france
dépense plus pour cent de son pib pour
la santé les etats-unis 18%
il ya eu des tentatives du président
obama de mort il ya un enjeu politique
sur la santé c'est une évidence
maintenant est-ce que le contrôle des
données de santé peut être un enjeu
politique
c'est pas impossible c'est à dire que y
compris alors c'est un outil avec ce que
ça peut avoir de pire et de meilleur en
août ils pouvaient mal utilisés à des
fins mauvaise comme vous pouvez
parfaitement l'utiliser dans votre
question est pertinente monsieur
sylvestre
on doit rester vigilants sur
l'utilisation des données ça fait bien
qu'il ait donnée personnelle oui le
voleur voilà rivaux alors bien sûr et
c'est là où évidemment la puissance
publique les normes européennes protège
les données personnelles de santé qui ne
doit pas être accessibles de façon
malveillante
merci beaucoup robert signal j'espère
vous revoir sur un plateau de télévision
plutôt que dans dans un hôpital mais
enfin je sais qu'on sera pas pour 26
manier merci en tous les cas à la grande
interview vous la retrouver
bien sûr en rediffusion en replay et
puis sur le site internet arte france
point tv
[Musique]